bonjour ayed chez ibi merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france
alors quelles conséquences ainsi cheveux
méchés si elle n'obtient pas la
confiance des députés
j'espère qu'on n'en arrivera pas là mais
en tout cas si i fé michy n'obtient pas
la confiance du gouvernement alors c'est
assez assez paradoxal mais on va tomber
dans un vide constitutionnel parce que
la constitution ne prévoit pas de cas de
figure en cas de non renouvellement en
tout cas de non confiance du de la part
de l'assemblée des représentants du
peuple dont il ya deux cas de figure ou
bien le gouvernement mais chichi passe
et c'est très bien pour la tunisie et je
le souhaite
ou bien il n'obtient pas la confiance et
à ce moment là on va continuer avec un
gouvernement d'expédition des affaires
courantes dirigé par reyes faire faire
en attendant une éventuelle décision de
la part du chef de l'état de dissoudre
le parlement parce que dans ce cas de
figure le présent la république peut
dissoudre mêlant n'est pas obligé donc
c'est pour ça qu'on arrive à on va dire
dans un espèce de vide et d'imbroglio
constitutionnel mais je ne pense pas
qu'on en arrivera là parce que tout
laisse à penser que hichem les chichis
obtiendra la confiance du parlement
troisième vote de confiance en un an
comment on explique comment vous
expliquer cette instabilité politique en
tunisie
tout simplement parce que la tunisie un
régime parlementaire qui repose
exclusivement sur des parties alors les
parties évidemment sont nécessaires à la
vie démocratique mais je pense que on
n'est plus dans un régime de parti que
dans un régime parlementaire et c'est
malheureusement le problème de la
tunisie actuellement c'est qu'on fait
plus de politique politicienne que de
politique que de politique pardon à
destination du peuple et malheureusement
cette instabilité là et ce flou aussi
autour de deux là comment dirais-je des
des points constitutionnel dans ces cas
de figure où il ya une instabilité
bah ça entraîne du flou sur du flou et
on en arrive à des imbroglios quand
comme on en a actuellement mais moi ce
que je constate malheureusement c'est
que
c'est un deuxième gouvernement en
l'espace de six mois je rappelle juste
que la tunisie traverse une grave crise
économique et sociale
depuis maintenant plusieurs années avec
notamment la crise du coc vite qu'ils
s'y ajoute je pense qu'il est vraiment
temps pour les responsables politiques
de d'assumer pleinement leurs
responsabilités et d'enfin enfin faire
de la politique à destination du peuple
et non plus à destination pour certains
de leurs propres ambitions
le problème de la tunis et que tant
qu'on aura un régime parlementaire
exclusivement fondée sur des parties on
n'arrivera pas à sortir de du gouffre de
là où nous sommes et qui attendent mais
les tunisiens de leur gouvernement les
mots d'ordre de la révolution et qui a
chassé ben ali était liberté travail
dignité
est ce que est ce que ces mots sont
toujours d'actualité chez les citoyens
tunisiens plus que jamais plus que
jamais la tunisie aujourd'hui le taux de
chômage en tunisie c'est de 18 % 18 % de
taux de chômage et qui risque d'ailleurs
d'après les prévisions de montée jusqu'à
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans ces cas là est
ce qu'on continue à à se balancer des
noms d'oiseaux au parlement comme c'est
le cas de la part d'une minorité certes
mais est ce qu'on continue comme ça où
est ce qu'on décide enfin de travailler
main dans la main pour proposer des
choses à destination notamment de cette
jeunesse qui réclament de l'emploi ce
que le problème principal en tunis et le
ce sont des problèmes économiques et
sociaux et notamment le problème de
l'emploi
comment on propose quelque chose je
dirais de novateur pour le développement
économique pour la formation
professionnelle pour réduire les
inégalités entre les régions
il ya plein de problématiques qui se
posent aujourd'hui en tunisie
mais tant qu'on aura malheureusement
certains parlementaires qui se
consacreront à des insultes ou bien à
faire de la politique politicienne
on n'en sortira pas de 7,2 de cette
problématique
donc j'espère vraiment que les
parlementaires auront un peu plus et
assumeront leur je dirais leur étiquette
c'est à dire des représentants du peuple
et qu'ils assumeront pleinement leurs
fonctions
la tunisie ne peut pas ne peut plus ne
doit plus être
encore dans cette situation où il ya un
blocage au parlement qui entraîne
ensuite un blocage du pays
très rapidement pour terminer on a on
n'a plus beaucoup le temps ryan chebbi à
l'instar de ses prédécesseurs le nouveau
premier ministre s'il obtient la
confiance du parlement va vite devoir
trouver des soutiens financiers à
l'extérieur du pays pour reconstruire un
la tunisie on pense à l'europe
c'est votre cas aussi oui bien sûr et
d'ailleurs j'ai envie de dire avant même
que ce soit une problématique du du du
futur je l'espère chef du gouvernement
et shem et chichis le président de la
république lui-même avait lancé un
certain nombre de projets de très beaux
projets par ailleurs je pense au tgv qui
va relier demain le nord au sud de
bizerte à ben laden je pense à la cité
médicale des aghlabites à kairouan et
bien évidemment l'europe est une actrice
majeure danse dans ces projets là et la
france bien sûr je rappelle que la
france est le premier partenaire
économique commercial et culturel de la
tunisie et elle se tiendra toujours aux
côtés de la tunisie notamment pour ses
projets à destination de la jeunesse et
des prochaines générations
merci beaucoup à iad shelby d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin sur les franges
rappel et que vous êtes président de
l'association pour la promesse pour la
promotion pardon de la coopération et de
l'amitié entre la france et la tunisie